et c'est l'heure de notre invité
politique bonjour Marielle de sarnaise
merci sera avec nous ce matin député
européenne vice-présidente du MoDem on
va parler de beaucoup de sujets avec
vous notamment de la situation nationale
bien sûr mais aussi internationale avec
l'Ukraine et que vous connaissez à très
bien d'abord une question sur Emmanuel
Macron c'est lui qui a fait l'actualité
à toute la semaine dernière voulu
donneriez la carte du MoDem au ministre
de l'Économie moi je crois pas que les
questions soient des questions de carte
politique à la vérité beaucoup de il a
le droit de pas avoir de cartes
d'ailleurs il y a des millions de
Français qui n'ont pas de carte moi je
suis militante j'aime les militants
politiques mais la politique ça peut pas
se résumer aux parties et c'est bien
comme ça est-ce que sa loi va dans le
bon sens la réponse est oui mais à quoi
on a assisté au fond bon c'est pas non
plus très satisfaisant c'est-à-dire ça
fait pas les grands vraies formes dont
la France a vitalement besoin depuis
maintenant des décennies mais ça va dans
le bon sens vous l'auriez voté oui moi
je l'aurais voté mais en face de ça au
fond on a des jeux de posture c'est à
dire que on a une partie de la gauche
qui dit c'est une droite droite donc de
votre part et en même temps on est à
droite qui dit ça vient de la gauche
donc on vote pas écoutez tout ça n'est
pas raisonnable tout ça n'est pas
sérieux à la vérité si on avait une
droite un centre fort à l'Assemblée
nationale au fond oui il aurait dû
soutenir c'est toi Macron qui n'est pas
absolument génial mais qui va simplement
dans le bon sens qui est déjà le début
de quelque chose
vous dites que la réforme même timide
est impossible en France que ça ne
pourra pas durer c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce
que vous voulez dire quand vous dites ça
ne pourra pas timide
3 c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait pas de
majorité or on a besoin vitalement de
réformes beaucoup plus profonde dans
notre pays on a besoin on va reparler de
la réforme des retraites on a besoin de
la réforme du Code du travail on a
besoin de redonner confiance aux
entreprises de créer un biotope
favorable au fond à la création et
notamment à la création de richesse et
on voit bien que pour le moment il n'y a
pas de majorité pour faire mais quand
vous dites ça ne va pas durer est-ce que
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on va dans le
mur qu'est-ce qui va soit on va renoncer
à faire des réformes si chacun reste
campé dans son dans son coin dans son
parti politique la droite contre la
gauche la gauche contre la droite et à
ce moment-là on va encore perdre du
temps pour notre pays et donc je le
regrette moi je veux dire de toutes mes
forces je veux que mon pays réussisse
mais pour ça il faut qu'il fasse des
réformes et ce qui peut faire des
réformes quand contre quand la réponse
est non c'est impossible la gauche ne
peut pas réformer toute seule d'ailleurs
il y a pas d'esprit de réforme suffisant
à gauche et la droite même si elle est
au pouvoir ne peut pas réformer toute
seule mais vous voyez bien que l'UMP ne
voudra jamais voter avec les les
socialistes ça veut dire que
ne sont pas dans un esprit mais il y a
pas eu de grandes réformes en France on
se raconte des histoires il y a pas eu
de grandes réformes ni ce François
Hollande ni sous Nicolas Sarkozy ni sous
Jacques Chirac regardons les choses en
face et il y a pas eu de grandes
réformes on a eu des hommes politiques
au fond qui ont je trouve moi pas très
bien géré la France depuis 30 ans ne
cherchez pas plus loin l'explication de
la montée du Front national le Front
national contraire bien sûr sur le
chômage bien sûr cela crise économique
et une forme de désespérance mais il
prospère sur une classe politique qui
n'a pas été efficace elle est pas
efficace parce qu'elle est dans deux
camps opposée et que ça c'est un système
qui ne peut pas fonctionner mercredi
Manuel Valls a rendez-vous avec les
syndicats qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
de ce dialogue social qui devrait en
principe repartir en tout cas moi je je
crois qu'il faut qu'on change de
logiciel au fond sur le dialogue social
je crois qu'il faut qu'on décentralise
beaucoup plus qu'on assouplisse je ne
crois plus aux grandes messes nationales
je ne crois pas que c'est comme ça qu'on
règle les affaires les problèmes on les
prend et on les traite dans l'entreprise
en faisant confiance au terrain il faut
changer il faut passer de la défiance ça
c'est le système français on est en
défiance avec tout le monde donc on met
des super contrôles on veut tout voir il
faut passer vers la confiance dans un
système de confiance je crois qu'il faut
avoir une autre approche du dialogue
social est-ce qu'il faut toucher
retoucher au 35 heures ce qu'il faut
retoucher au seuil sociaux il faut de
possibilité alors on a dit que le
gouvernement allait peut-être le faire
mais j'ai lu la petite phrase en disant
on va mettre de la souplesse dans les
entreprises quand elles sont en train de
faire faillite ça c'est très très
intelligent peut-être qu'on pourra en
mettre avant qu'elle fasse faillite vous
voyez ce sont des choses vraiment toutes
simples on voit bien que la France est
très très loin au fond des réformes
qu'elle doit engager pas pour avoir des
difficultés mais pour mieux vivre pour
mieux fonctionner ensuite on est à moi
des élections départementales le Front
National est en tête des intentions de
vote c'est le sondage à hip-hop a publié
dans Le Figaro ce matin 30% des
intentions de vote devons l'UMP et le
centre devant le PS le FN ancré au
niveau local qu'est-ce que le FN a de
plus que le modem aujourd'hui qui
devrait représenter l'alternative ah
mais nous en tous les cas au centre nous
avons une responsabilité quand le centre
est fort le Front National est beaucoup
plus bas que la vue en 2007 avec
François Bayrou c'est pas le cas parce
que le centre est dispersé parce que la
moitié des centristes sont allés à l'UMP
enfin ça c'était il y a très longtemps
donc moi je préfère pas regarder mais
vous avez absolument raison mais il faut
que le centre décide d'exister nous de
toute notre force c'est ce que nous
portons avec François bayrouet je pense
que c'est nécessaire pour le pays et
donc très très important mais c'est vrai
que le Front national prospère je
voulais dire au fond sur une classe
politique qui n'a pas su mettre son
énergie au service des Français depuis
30 ans qui donnent des promesses à
chaque campagne promesse qui sont pas
tenues et qui sont pas respectées le
lendemain donc il faut pas s'en étonner
vous parlez de François Bayrou qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait vous qui êtes très
proche de François bayroude de le voir
siffler à chaque meeting quasiment
Nicolas Sarkozy je pense que Nicolas
Sarkozy franchement dans ce rôle de
espèce de surveillance générale tout ça
est complètement mais mais complètement
dépassé c'est absolument caricatural
comme manière de faire de la politique
qui peut imaginer que ce qui est à faire
dans le pays pourra l'être les uns
contre les autres les partis politiques
sont comportant comme des sectes c'est
le contraire de l'esprit qu'il faut
avoir il faut avoir un esprit
d'ouverture sur un esprit de
construction moi je ferai tout pour que
la prochaine élection présidentielle
elle soit directement utile au pays je
dis à c'est à dire qu'elle permettent au
lendemain l'élection des rassemblements
larges chacun restant ce qu'il est mais
au service du pays exactement ce que je
redeur
par exemple à ce moment-là la vérité si
on regarde l'échiquier politique il faut
des rassemblements làges de la droite
républicaine représentée par JP jusque
grosso modo socio-démocrate représenté
par Valls et en passant par le centre et
pareil
les schémas somaliens menace la France
d'attentats ce matin notamment dans des
centres commerciaux qu'est-ce que le
Parlement européen vous qui êtes député
européenne a fait depuis les attentats
de Charlie Hebdo depuis les attentats du
de l'hypercacher contre le les
terroristes bah écoutez on a accéléré
évidemment la coordination des
renseignements de l'information c'est
absolument vital moi je pense que notre
mise intérieure c'est tout à fait bien
débrouillé européens ils ont décidé
d'avancer ensemble de mettre en place ce
fameux PNR européen c'est-à-dire la
coordination des données de tous ceux
qui prennent l'avion il faut renforce
les instruments qui existent comme
Europole comme au juste on le voit bien
et il faut qu'on aille plus loin je
pense qu'il faut par exemple on est des
contrôles systématique systématique au
frontières de Schengen donc je crois
qu'il faut encore aller plus loin que ce
qui a été décidé vous étiez sur la place
mydan il y a un an au moment des
rassemblements qui ont fait tomber
Victoria nukovitch je me suis un très
bien que vous étiez très enthousiaste à
l'époque un an après ça vous fait quoi
de voir toutes ces images j'étais
enthousiaste parce que au fond les
Ukrainiens se débarrasser d'un régime
qui était corrompu n'oubliez pas ça les
gens sur maïdan qu'est-ce qu'il disait
il disait on ne veut plus de la
corruption et il y avait pas la guerre
alors après moi je n'ai jamais pensé que
l'Ukraine devait par exemple rentrer
dans l'Union européenne et ça je crois
que c'était une erreur d'appréciation
d'un certain nombre d'Européens alors on
voit bien les pays baltes la Pologne qui
ont vécu ce qu'ils ont vécu avec
soviétique et qui évidemment se disent
que une Ukraine dans l'Union européenne
ça l’enquerait définitivement loin de la
Russie ça n'est pas la solution la
solution maintenant c'est les accords de
risque de on voit bien dans quel état
ils sont aujourd'hui mais il faut que
Vladimir Poutine arrête de jouer avec le
feu c'est à dire de nous faire il y a
que la démocratie qui peut régler la
question et par derrière d'avancer
d'avancer pour conquérir des territoires
il y a un moment où ça pourra plus ça ne
devra plus fonctionner sur nos images
dans nos reportage on voit des des
habitants de l'Est du pays de l'Ukraine
Qui qui crie au scandale qui qui parle
d'un assassin en parlant de Porto qu'il
est bombarde
bombardé par la guerre civile c'est très
difficile l'Ukraine elle est placée
géographiquement stratégiquement et
politiquement entre l'Europe et la
Russie donc la vérité il faut avancer
Europe
Ukraine Russie ça c'est absolument une
évidence mais il faut aussi que les
dirigeants ukrainiens et ça on l'a dit
depuis le début conseil d'une autonomie
fédéralise leur système politique ce
qu'ils avaient malheureusement refusé de
faire Éliane merci beaucoup merci